we've talked about things that are
invisible so bacteria are basically
invisible to our eyes and yet were
covered with them they're on us they're
in us they're everywhere and scientists
have known about bacteria for almost 400
years and what bacteria are are these
primitive single celled organisms but
the way that they grow is they just grow
twice their size they cut themselves
down in the middle and then one becomes
two and so for all of these 400 years
everyone has thought that these bacteria
are so primitive that they're just out
there acting like these little asocial
organisms but what we thought about and
think about now is that there's no
possibility that a bacteria could
accomplish all the things they managed
you most like making us sick i mean lots
of terrible things but also lots of
wonderful things if they're just acting
as these little individuals because they
couldn't have an influence on the
environment and so what we've shown and
what quorum sensing is is that bacteria
make and release tiny little molecules
that you can think of like hormones and
so as the cells grow in numbers these
molecules grow on the outside of the
cells and when the molecules hit a
certain amount which is proportional to
cell number the bacteria detect that
those molecules are there so it's a way
of counting neighbors and then all the
bacteria change their their behavior in
unison and so they start carrying out
tasks as enormous groups instead of
trying to accomplish these tasks as
individuals and I mean so it's just like
what we do you know if you need to move
a piano from here to there you don't do
it yourself you wait you get all your
friends and then you go one two three
and everybody does it together and so so
we call it quorum sensing so they sort
of vote with these chemical votes they
count the vote and then they say we have
enough to do it and then they do it
whatever it is